une files d'attentes qui ne désemplit
pas au checkpoint de shaar ephraïm
transformés en centres de vaccination
des centaines de travailleurs
palestiniens présentent leur carte
d'identité et leur permis de travail
dans l'état hébreu
le sésame pour être vacciné contre le
coc vite 19 je conseille à tous les
frères travailleurs qui veulent se faire
vacciner de venir et si dieu le veut
ce sera une bonne chose pour nous c'est
bon pour le travail et nous pouvons
aller où nous voulons voulons vivre
notre vie normale et on finir avec la
maladie si dieu le veut ils meurent en a
marre et akram viennent de recevoir une
dose du vaccin moderna comme eux cent
mille palestiniens travaillant dans les
colonies ou en israël vont être vaccinés
contre le coronavirus l'autorité
palestinienne et l'état hébreu ont passé
un accord en février pour organiser
cette campagne de vaccination menée par
des équipes médicales israéliennes
depuis plusieurs semaines des ong des
responsables palestinien appelé israël à
fournir des vaccins aux palestiniens de
cisjordanie et de la bande de gaza sous
blocus israélien
pour le moment les palestiniens n'ont
reçu qu'un peu plus de 30 mille doses de
vaccins dont 2000 d'israël tel aviv
s'est engagé à en fournir cinq mille
depuis le début de la pandémie
près de 140 de 1000 cas de coronavirus
et environ 1600 décès ont été recensés
en cisjordanie occupée